In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God
to place my absolute nothingness in the heart of the most holy trinity,
to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my existence
by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live,
pray, act, eat, walk, sleep, and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants, or desires,
and may you my beloved divine will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately
that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure
and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will
that you never perceive even a breath of resistance
in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the angels and
saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead,
to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light
so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings
and prayers. Amen. So I want to begin with June the 20th
1925 and Jesus talks to us about how we can have
heaven on earth in this passage. Louisa said I felt immersed in the
holy will of God and my sweet Jesus drawing me to himself
clasped me in his arms very tightly and said my daughter
how beautiful is the rest that the divine will has in his soul
when that will is there as life as distinct from just simply doing the
divine will and a soul who lets my will act
and love entirely and completely. This is all relevant to our fear.
It's very wonderful. The Lord has just given it to us at the right moment.
Okay, so he wants to rest in us but he needs to be there
as the Lord. He needs to be there as the dominant one.
He needs to be able to act with love, divine love within us so he needs
us given to him entirely and completely. Now notice
there isn't a bit left for us. It's entirely and completely handed over.
You must know he said as the soul breeds palpitates operates and everything
else that takes place in her since my will is in her as the center
of her life. This is the operative thing. He's looking
for this that we will hand over completely to him
because that's when he's free to do what he needs to do
in order to reign on the earth. So since my will is in her as the center of her
life, it is my will that breeds in her. It's my will
that palpitates. It's my will that gives motion to her work.
It's my will that's in the circulation of her blood
and everything else. Since this will is the same as that
which is in the most holy trinity, the three divine persons,
it happens that they feel within themselves the breath of that soul.
It's not incredible. They feel her heartbeat and they feel
her motion. That's why you're going to hear in a moment
when Louisa has a little flip in doubting that he says that that
all of heaven was shook because the same divine will that's operating in heaven
is operating in the soul. Also he said every time our will decides
to do an act, it makes new joys, new beatitudes,
new happiness come out of us, which harmonizing
everything among the divine persons, they form immense
seas of new happiness. Now notice everything is new.
God is a creator. He will not patch up something. Do you remember Jesus said
that Christianity was not a patch on Judaism?
Okay, he won't patch something up. He'll make something completely new
and that's what he wants to do with us as well.
Make something completely new and beautiful for God.
And as he's able to operate in us, he wants to produce new beatitudes.
Now a new beatitude is something that hasn't been there before
and therefore all of heaven benefits from this, all of earth benefits from this,
all of purgatory benefits from this, the three kingdoms.
So as every time our will decides to do an act,
it makes new joy, new beatitudes, new happiness
come out of us and they harmonize with the three divine persons naturally
because it's the one will and they form immense
seas. Everything to do with God is immense because he's eternal,
he's infinite, immense seas of new happiness which
enveloping all the blessed in heaven cause them to remain enraptured within
these joys. Isn't that utterly amazing that
if we allowed the Lord to operate the way he wants
in us, then we can be the cause of the saints in heaven having new happiness
and new joy. And this causes them to remain enraptured
in these joys and to be shaken by this rapture when our will
wants to form more acts of the will in order to delight us and to make us
issue more beatitudes. They are just so totally captured
by this extraordinary immense endless movement of new life, new
beatitudes, new joy, new everything, but he wants to do that for us as well.
Now because of this, the soul on earth understood,
who lets our will live within herself, reaches such a point
that as she lets the divine will operate. Now notice as she lets that's the
continuous surrender and abandonment to the divine will,
which is moment by moment and day by day.
As she allows the divine will to operate, she gives us the most blessed Trinity,
the occasion to put our beatitudes and the harmonies and the infinite joys of
our love into motion. So here is this little nothing on earth,
allowing the divine will to operate in her,
and he's saying that that gives him the opportunity
to do all of this wonder for all the saints in heaven.
Of course, the souls and poverty benefit as well and everybody on earth.
It gives us the occasion to put out our beatitudes and harmonies and
infinite joys. She makes us issue new beauties
of ours. It's no wonder he wants us to surrender.
Our will operating in the creature is so
very pleasing, tender and lovable to us.
It gives us new surprises because the creature still has free will and can
decide I'll do this, I'll do that, I'll do the other. So we can even give
surprises to God, it's amazing. It gives us new surprises.
It puts our things in motion to give us the return of our glory,
our love and our happiness. And all this
by means of the creature who has given the place within herself to allow
the divine will to live. Now there's the operative bit and if you have your own
book, that's the bit you underline, you color it.
And it all happens because the creature gives
a place within herself to allow the divine will to live.
So he said, how could you not love this birth from our will?
The birth from the divine will is the soul
surrendered and allowing the divine will to work.
More so, since our will renders this creature more lovable, more gracious and
more beautiful to us, in such a way that in no one else
do we see her prerogatives? Naturally it's not in anybody else because if the
others have not surrendered and abandoned themselves to the
divine will, then the divine will can't operate that way.
She is a work done by our will. That's Ephesians
210. We are God's work of art created in Christ Jesus.
She is a work done by our will with such mastery
as to enchant the whole of heaven. Now when you go back to the book of Genesis
chapter two, you have this wonderful description
of the extraordinary amount of attention
that God gave to making the first man. In fact it's described as if God was
making a statue and only when he breathed life
into that statue did it become a living being. Now this is going to be important
as we go on in the messages tonight. So this person is a work of art
that God has done an enormous amount of work within it and you see in the
volumes that we have studied in Louisa that the Lord continues to work within
her and sometimes she says, what are you doing?
And he says, well I'm housekeeping or I'm doing something.
But he's always working within her and he needs to expand
our soul so that we can take more of the divine will.
She is a work done by our will with such mastery as to enchant the whole of
heaven and to render her lovable to all that's all the saints and all the angels
at all the souls in purgatory. And even more so to the most holy trinity.
It's fascinating. And while he was saying this, Louisa said, he clasped me more
tightly and letting me place my mouth in his heart.
Now it has to mean on his heart or towards the,
it's probably the wound in his side that she's actually talking about.
Jesus said, you too drink our beatitudes in large gulps,
satiate yourself and as you want and take as much as you want. Now I want to give
you Sam 36 verses 8 to 9, Lord they feast on the abundance of your house
and you give them to drink from the river of the lights
because you are the fountain of life. I also want to give you
Isaiah chapter 12 verses 1 to 6 and it ends this way,
drink deep from the wells of salvation. That's why it's most likely the open
wound in the heart of Jesus that she's asked to put her lips to.
Let's come to June the 25th, 1925 and this is a very important message
for understanding Jesus' words and actions and what he wants from us as well.
This is very important for the consecration in August.
Louisa said, as I was in my usual state my adorable Jesus all love and tenderness
came to my poor soul. First he placed himself near me
and he fixed his gaze on me as if he wanted to tell me lots of things.
But instead of that he actually wanted to expand my intelligence.
This is terribly important for us because as we study the writings of
Louisa I'm sure you've come up against stuff
that you didn't really grasp. Not because you couldn't understand the
words on the book but because your relationship with God
hadn't come to that place where that could enter in.
So it's actually important to actually say to the Lord,
please expand my intelligence. Give me understanding,
expand my soul and if you're hesitating about the the consecration at all
a prayer that the Lord gave to me many years ago when I was surrendering to him.
I said, tell me what to say to you. I do that all the time. I say, Lord, you give
me the words. You put the thoughts into my head.
You put the words into my mouth. And what he said was,
say these words, Lord, take me from myself and give me today.
That's a wonderful thing. It just absolutely says everything.
Take me from myself and give me today. And so here
Louisa finds that he's expanding her intelligence.
Now this is 17 volumes into the most extraordinary
experience that a human being could have and he's still expanding her
intelligence because if he's to give her more
the intelligence must be expanded. And he has made it very clear
that as you grow, as you continue to study in these volumes,
if the growth doesn't actually go along with your study,
then it'll become quite obtuse to you. But he wanted to expand my intelligence
because it was incapable of receiving and understanding.
Now receiving and understanding are two different things.
You could hear the words that I'm saying. You
understand the English language. You know what I'm saying
in words. But to understand that in the depths of your being is another matter
altogether. You've got to be in a particular
place in your relationship with God for that.
And then Jesus laid himself over my whole person
and he hid me under himself. He covered my face with his,
my hands and my feet with his. It seemed to me that he was all
attentive, uncovering me and hiding him under himself.
Everything is through him with him and in him.
He is our divine ladder. It's him. I want to give you
Psalm 32 verse 7. You are my hiding place, O Lord.
I want to give you Psalm 57 1. Hide me under the shadow of your wings.
I want to give you Matthew 23 verse 37 where Jesus said,
I want to put you under my wings like a hen puts her chicks under the wings.
He always gives her a very graphic experience
so that she goes from this very graphic experience to try and tell us
what this means on a spiritual level. So she said she felt very happy, hidden
and covered by Jesus. And then she goes on and she tells us that
she forgets all about her sufferings and forgets all about the privations and
everything else. And it's like as if, oh heaven is back, this is fantastic.
So let's move down the page a little bit. So after he kept me all covered and
hidden within himself for some time to the point where I thought he'd never
leave me again because that's the issue all the time with Louisa.
I heard him call the angels and the saints to come and see what he was doing
with me and to come and see the way that he covered me up with his
entire person. And then afterwards he shared his pains
with me. Now in volume 17 this is quite unusual.
It was the normal thing in the earlier volumes and then he moved her away from
that into a higher plane and it seems strange
that he comes back to give her more pains but watch what he's going to say.
As long as we are on earth we cannot avoid pain and suffering. We just cannot do it.
And he's going to tell her that the Lord uses trials and difficulties
that we experience in relationships and in ourselves and in circumstances he
uses everything, the pain and suffering of our lives,
to bring us deeper and to bring us much further in the relationship with him.
So here is Louisa with the extraordinary relationship that she has
and she's still experiencing this. So she said
afterwards he shared his pains with me and I let him do everything. You see
she's abandoned to him and even though I felt as though being crushed by those
pains I felt happy and I experienced the joys
which the divine will contains when the soul
abandons herself to it even in suffering. Now you really need to take
that sentence and really look at it. She's first of all she said
that the sufferings were so great that she actually felt crushed
and then she balances it up completely by saying
but I also experienced the joy of being abandoned in the divine will.
The joy of being abandoned in the divine will
balances out the pain so I want to give you Hebrews 12
too where the author tells us that for the joy that was said before him
Jesus endured the cross despising the shame, joy and suffering together.
What makes suffering unbearable is that when we don't have the inner joy
of union with God and therefore we don't have that abandonment to God and the
suffering seems to be useless and having no meaning
but in this surrendered state everything is full of meaning and full of grace.
This is very important so now he goes on to tell us
that if we're going to abandon ourselves to him
and to pronounce a fiat for him the thing we need most
is understanding. We need to grasp the enormity of the grace that he's giving
to us and then he says himself the actual
surrender is not difficult but if you don't understand it the surrender
is difficult so this is a very important section
and then after Jesus made me suffer he told me my daughter
my will wants to give itself to you more and more as long as we're
on the earth the Lord wants us to reach a fullness.
If your journey is finished he'll take you home.
If he hasn't taken you home your journey is not finished
and if your journey is not finished there is more to experience
there is more to suffer there is more to grow and
there is more honor and glory that we are to give to God
and so every moment of every day is extremely special.
So the divine will he said wants to give itself to you more
and more but in order to give itself more
it wants to make itself understood more. Now we've already used that example
some time ago Jesus himself gave it a few volumes back
of a person holding a jewel in their hands and they have no idea
of its value and therefore you don't just throw it there it's just
something you know and then they go and they have it
valued and the first person that values it says
thousand euro oh so now this thing is worth a thousand euro
so i'm not going to throw it around the place you go to somebody else and he's
an expert in this area and he says thousand euro
that's worth a million or two and then all of a sudden you discover
well i didn't know i was a millionaire it's a bit like that with us in the
divine will and that's why Jesus used that example
so here Jesus is saying if i'm to give you more of my divine will
you have to understand it because if you don't understand it
you are not going to value it and if you don't value it you won't use it
properly so you have to understand more
and in order to render what the divine will manifest to you
more stable in other words you're not going to be
losing it and safer and more estimable now estimable means
worthy of admiration and respect in other words
i'm now respecting this gem that i have discovered is worth a couple of
million the divine will in order to achieve
that gives you new pains okay the sufferings and the trials
give us understanding the sufferings and the trials
also give us wisdom now anybody who has been through a time
of great suffering and trial knows and if you
endure it for the love of god then you'll find that
you'll come out of it a much wiser person than you were before
so the sufferings and the trials are therefore very important
and we might have the idea that you know once you surrender to the divine will
everything's going to be love joy and peace after that
not when you're on the earth because you have to grow there's a whole journey
and it's the whole mission to accomplish so the divine will gives you new pains
so as to dispose you more watch this now
and to prepare in you the empty space now we have this extraordinary ability to
say oh no i'm surrendered to the lord i've given my
fear you know i gave it to him a few years ago
but there's still a little bit of yourself there
and so he scours out more and more space for himself
by using these cleaning methods that he has
called trials and sufferings and so he needs to get us to the place where the
self is gone self will is gone everything is gone
so we're ready for the new creation so he wants
empty space now saint rays of lisue said that in different words
she said that you must go to god with empty hands every single day
if you want him to fill your hands with treasures
okay so watch that empty space bill and if you are sincere about abandoning
yourself to the lord then he will give you an opportunity
to let go and let go and let go so that there is in fact
enough space for him to come i think i told you before
that Elizabeth Wang who's wonderful spiritual paintings can be found on
radiant light.org she painted a picture of a soul
just having received holy communion and she painted the soul
like a container and she had the lord sitting on the edge of the container
looking in a little puzzled now he had just been received in holy communion
and the container which was the soul which should have been empty to receive
him to receive the fullness instead of that it was full of all kinds of boxes
tall and small and fashion tin not necessarily
sinned but the junk of every this stuff that we
like to collect and plot her and all the rest of it in our inside of ourselves
and the memories of the past that we just won't let go and blah blah blah
and so the lord looks in and there's actually no space for him
and so while the person has received holy communion
they receive very little benefit that's very sad
so what he's saying to us in the divine will is
do your spring cleaning empty out all those
corners where you've you've filled up with all kinds of stuff
and give me the space and i'll come because the divine will wants the noble
courtage of pain in order to be sure that the soul
be sure about the soul and to be able to trust her
it's not absolutely incredible but if we provide him with the empty space
he knows he he can do it because we've got rid of the thing in us the self
that will oppose him it's always pain and crosses he said
that opened the doors to new manifestations of god
haven't we all got testimony and multiple testimonies of that
it's always pain in crossings that opened the doors to more secret lessons
and to the greatest gifts in which i want to place in you
so he has to allow the trials and the crosses and the sufferings
in order for those doors to open in fact if the soul bears my suffering and
sorrowful will she will become capable of receiving
my delighting will now we've watched that in louisa
in the early volumes she takes all this suffering
and then she knows the ecstasy of the divine will taking over in her
in fact if the soul bears the suffering and sorrowful will
she will become capable of receiving my delighting will
and will acquire the hearing in order to understand new lessons
now knows that's interior hearing that's not external stuff
she will acquire the hearing pain will make her acquire the celestial
language in such a way that she will be able to repeat the new lessons that
she has learned so if we don't allow the lord to put us
through this school of the wilderness is what i call it
then we're not going to reach the promised land of the divine will
so in the next paragraph oh dear he's going to ask for
complete sacrifice on hearing this louisa said to him
my jesus and my life she said it seems to me
that it takes complete sacrifice in order to do your will and to live in it
at first sight it seems nothing it's very interesting when you come to
read these writings first not all that difficult
after you try and put the will out but then in the practice it's difficult
because not my will but then be done all the time in absolutely everything
not having a single breath of one's own will even and holy things
in good itself seems to me to be too painful for human nature
there's louisa in touch with reality therefore
will souls ever be able to come to live in the divine will
with complete sacrifice that's the core ban
handed over and jesus said my daughter everything
lies in understanding the great good that comes to her by doing my will
everything is in the understanding if i understand that this gem
actually has a value of two or three million as distinct from me throwing
it there thinking that no value at all that changes everything
he said everything is in understanding the great good that comes to her
by doing my will what in understanding what this will
is which wants the sacrifice and everything is in understanding how this
will does not adapt itself to mixing and living with a low small and finite
will the infinite perfect and eternal will of god
cannot mix with my low small and finite will
which is messes things up it can't happen
so you might have one or the other so he's saying really it's all or nothing
the divine will wants to render the acts of the soul
who wants to live in my will he wants to render them eternal
he wants to render those acts infinite and he
wants to make them divine that's why we've got to get rid of the junk
and how can the divine will do this
if the soul wants to put the breath of her human will
even in a holy thing i'm not sure what louisa means by holy things
whether she means going to mass or prayers or whatever
because it is actually possible i've taught spirituality for years
and it is actually possible for a person to be indulging in their own self
in prayer when prayer is easy for them they're enjoying prayer they're having
peace in prayer so they spend hours in prayer
so if the lord gives them any erudity and prayer then and another not going to
do it because what they were doing was was actually giving
into themselves they weren't really praying
a person who's really praying will pray even hanging out of a cliff
they'll pray at the bottom of the sea a person who really needs contact with
god it's totally different and so even in a holy
thing is it's really very important because
the human will can be very dominant in everything
i gave you the example of working in a parish
in another country and i went to the church early in the morning which is
my habit when i was staying in a parish
and with the church all empty i absolutely love it i just say lord this is great
it's just tea and maids wonderful and
we were getting on with with sort of just being together when a person came in
this is all right i wouldn't have a problem the church is big it can hold a
couple hundred but that person who came in was a
woman who walked straight up to me literally dug her elbow into me
and said get out that's my place she did not gen effect she did not recognize
the presence of god she sinned against her neighbor
and she was in a house of god and she had come
early from us obviously to say her prayers
i think that's what she's talking about that even in holy things you can sin
that was a terrible shock for me so naturally enough i got up and put a big
space between me and her since the divine will and the very faulty
sinful human will cannot mix one of them has to go
okay how can the divine will do this if she wants to put the breath of her
human will even in a holy thing because the human will is always
finite and you can't mix finite with infinite
and then the living in my will he said would no longer be reality it would only
be words now that that would be one of the temptations
that people could have is that they would say divine will prayers
that they would do the exercises but they would not hand over their will to
god that they would not abandon themselves to god and therefore
it's all still external because if i don't hand over my will to god the divine
will cannot come and live in me he says that himself very clearly
what would you say he said if a little lamp or a match
or a spark of fire wanted to enter the sun if you wouldn't mind
and to make its own way and to form its field of light and action in the
center of the sun it's laughable if the sun had reason it would become
indignant and its light and heat would annihilate the little lamp the match
and the spark and you'd be the first one to mock them
you'd condemn their boldness in wanting to form their own field of action within
the light of the sun i mean the sheer ridiculousness of that
is self-evident and he said such is the breath of the human will
within mind we don't realize that it is an insult to the divine majesty
to think that my will can take over from his
even in good things you're good things there's your prayer and you're
going to mass and all the rest of it okay therefore he said be attentive
that in nothing may your will have life
nothing i want to give you Galatians 220 i no longer live
Christ lives in me i've i'm surrendered i've handed myself over
and so he said to louisa i covered you and hid you
completely within myself that you may have no i but to look at my will alone
that you would give the divine will free field of action in your soul
rather the difficulty will be in understanding the living of the divine
will not in sacrificing yourself because if i
want a car very very badly i'll go to all the lengths i need to go to to find
the finance and get that car if you're a woman and you really have
your eyes set on a particular outfit you'll get it
and he's saying that if only we understood the enormity of the privilege
of having the divine will reigning in us that we pay any price
and the surrendering of ourselves would be nothing
he said the problem will be in understanding the living in the divine will
not in sacrificing yourself i find that fascinating
in fact once they've understood the great good that comes to them
that from being poor they now become rich from being slaves to their vile
passions they become free and dominating from being servants they become masters
from being unhappy they become happy even amid the pains of this poor life
and all the goods which are in my divine will the total sacrifice of
everything would be an honor there you have the answer now
given by himself the total sacrifice of everything would be an honor for them
it would be desired it would be wanted it would be longed for
and this is why i push you so much to manifest what regards my will
because everything will be in understanding it
knowing it and loving it now if you're going to join me
on the 15th of August but i certainly hope you do
eat these words i digest them
so louisa said by jesus if you so much love and want
that this will of yours be known that it may have its field of divine action
within souls she says why don't you yourself manifest the truths to souls
and the great good which her will contains and the great good which
she said your direct word would have a magic force
a powerful magnet and you would have this creative power in your word
oh how difficult it is not to surrender to this sweet enchantment of your divine
word so if things are said directly by you
all will surrender now louisa is actually speaking quite
logically because we would all feel that way
but jesus said sorry that's not the way we work
my daughter he said it is my usual way that in the order of my eternal wisdom
to manifest my gracious works in one soul first
he did it in our blessed mother for redemption and he's doing it in louisa
for the fiat of sanctification it's my usual way to centralize in her
all the good that my work contains to deal with her
one on one as if nobody else existed and when i've done everything in such a way
as to be able to say that i have accomplished the work
completely within her that's philippians one six the lord
will complete the work he has begun in you and i do it so much so that there
will be nothing lacking to her it's only then that i let it flow
as though from a vast sea for the good of everybody else
i did the same with my celestial mother first i dealt with her as if
nobody else for the they work up the redemption
no other creature even knew anything that was going on
she disposed herself to all sacrifices and to all the necessary preparations in
order to make me descend from heaven to earth
i did everything as if she was the only redeemed one
which of course she was because she had been redeemed from the very instant
of her being but after she delivered me to the light
in such a way that all could see me and take the goods of redemption
i gave myself to everybody provided that they wanted to receive me and of course
it's the same with the divine will provided
people actually want god to reign in them so the big question we have to ask
ourselves is do i really want god to reign in me
he said it's the same what happened with my will
once i've completed everything within you in such a way that my will will triumph
in you and then light water the divine will flow
for the good of everybody but it was necessary to form the first soul
and then all the others will come afterwards it's exactly the same in the
book of genesis which chapter two verse seven where he
created Adam and then afterward once he gave this
enormous amount of attention to this first statue
i'm using that language because you're going to hear it
and then afterwards let the whole of humanity develop
so let's come to june the 29th 1925 this is where louisa has her doubt
and she gets a very strong reaction from the lord
so she says at the beginning i was feeling oppressed and so on
and she said at all wanted to disturb the serenity of my mind
and if you found yourself at the point of death and doubts and fears came to you
about the way you conducted yourself during your life to the point
of making your doubt about your salvation what would you do
now somebody living in the divine will okay
but as i was thinking about this jesus gave me no time to reflect any further
or to answer my thought moving in my interior he made himself
seen shaking his head and as though saddened by my thought he said my
daughter what are you saying in other words
don't you understand all the stuff i've been
saying to you about the divine will this massive revelation that he's been
giving now if she's having difficulties with it
then i i have mercy on you and me
to even think about this he said is an affront to my will
neither fears nor doubts nor any danger at all
can enter into the divine will these are things which do not belong to the
divine will when you have the divine will reigning in you
heaven has come to earth what is there to doubt or worry about
rather these are the miserable rags of the human will
again the human will wanting to interfere wanting to intervene
my will is like a placid see and i've told you for a number of years
that one of the signs of how well you're doing
in the divine will is that the peace that passes all understanding is
deepening within you my will is like a placid see
that murmurs peace happiness safety and certainty
and the waves it releases from its bosom are waves of joys and contentments
without end he said in seeing you think about this he said
i was shaken my will is not capable of fears
doubts and danger and the soul who lives in the divine will
becomes estranged from the miserable rags of the human will
ah underlying that in a whole lot of colors
the soul who lives in my will becomes estranged from all that misery and
awfulness that you had before and besides what could my will fear
who can ever raise doubts about the divine will's operating
if before the sanctity of the divine will everything trembles
and everything is forced to lower their heads adoring
the divine will even more he said i want to tell you something very
consoling for you now he's explaining why
doubts and difficulties that that about the divine will have just got to go
this is wonderful as he says to her i want to tell you something very
consoling for you and of great glory to me
it will happen with you and you're dying in time
as it happened for me in my dying
wow in life he said i operated i prayed i preached i introduced the
sacraments i suffered unheard of pains and even death itself
but i can say that my humanities saw almost nothing i mean
it seemed as if the fruits you know were hardly there
compared to the great good that the divine will had done
nor did the very sacraments have life as long as i remained on the earth
but as soon as i died my death put a seal on all my works
all my words all my pains and the sacraments
and the fruit of my death i want to give you Matthew 7 20
by their fruits you will know them and the fruit of my death confirmed
everything i did and made my works my pains my words
my sacraments which i instituted as well as the continuation of their life
until the end of the world made them all rise again
so my death put my works into motion
and made them rise again to perennial or everlasting life
all this was right in fact since my humanity contained the eternal word
and a divine will which is no beginning and no end
and which is not subject to dying nothing was to perish
of everything that it did not even a single word
but everything was to have continuation until the end of centuries
so you look at Jesus dying on the cross and people
looking externally at that thought they were looking at total failure
how wrong they were and will continue until the end of centuries in order to
pass into heaven to beatify the blessed eternally
the same will happen to you that is the incredible thing
he tells Louisa my will and we're not even halfway through these
these writings my will he said
which lives in you speaks to you and makes you operate and suffer
will let nothing perish not even a single word
of the many truths that i've manifested to you about my will
it will put everything in motion it will make everything rise again
your death will be the confirmation of everything i've told you
and since in the living of my will everything that the soul does suffers
praise and says contains an act of the divine will
all this will not be subject to dying but will remain in the world
like many lives notice remain in the world
working away all in the act of giving life to others
therefore your death will tear the veils that cover all the truths that i've
spoken to you and they will rise again like many
suns such as to dispel all the doubts and difficulties with which they
seemed to be covered in life now during
Louisa's lifetime the priests who were guiding her and helping her
they were quite puzzled because they'd never come across this before
it just didn't fit into the pattern of victims soul that they knew
and they realized that this was a revelation that hadn't happened before
so there was all kinds of questions and difficulties about it
and jesus said that with her death that would all lift
so your death will tear the veils that cover the truths
and they will rise again like many suns such as to dispel all the doubts and
difficulties which they seem to be covered with in life
so as long as you live in this low world you will see
little or nothing in others and there's the headline for us as well
that we must not look for obvious results while we are alive
they will be afterwards you will see little or nothing of
in others of all the great good which my will wants to do through you but
after your death it will have its full effect and you see that the divine will
is flowing like a river around the world now
Louisa said after this i spent the night without being able to close my eyes either
to sleep or to receive the usual visits of my beloved jesus
since when he comes i doze off within him and
for me this is more than sleep now for her dozing off is actually going into
ecstasy for the rest of us however i spent that night
doing the hours of the passion and doing the usual rounds in his adorable will
when i saw what was daylight this happens to me often she said
uh i said to myself my love neither did you come nor did you let me sleep
so how shall i go on today without you at that moment jesus moved
in my interior telling me now watch this my daughter
in my will there are no nights and no
sleep now that does not mean you can't go to bed and have a night sleep
what he's trying to tell her is about the eternal day
that when you enter into the divine will you're actually entering into the
eternal day i want to give you some 121 verse 4
the lord who watches over his people neither slumbers nor sleeps
and we know from maria val torta in her wonderful
revelation about the the ministry of jesus that jesus actually slept very
little he spent his nights in prayer when you go to the end of the book of
revelation and you find the new geruslem and you find
that it doesn't have sunlight or daylight it's lit by the glory of god
and it is perennial day now perennial day is that everybody is living
this divine life on the earth so that's what he means by it's always full
daylight and full vigil there's no time to sleep
because there's so much to do now there's the old idea that
some of us got when we were children but heaven would be a very boring place
because you're just sitting on a cloud playing a harp
there's no time to sleep because there's so much to do and there's so much
to take and there's so much to be happy with in the divine will
therefore you must learn to live in the long day of my will
so that my will may have its life and continuous
attitude or working within you so that the divine will is working in an
unbroken way as it is in heaven however you will find the most beautiful
rest Matthew 11 28 to 30 because my will will make you rise more
and more into your god now he is actually describing heaven
because at whatever level you enter heaven you grow
more and more and more we would say with time
the only way we're able to express it and so as you grow more and more and more
you become more and more and more and more like him
so that when the saints actually show themselves to us
they're actually quite different to what they were on earth
because every second again using our language that they are
in the glory of heaven they're being transformed more and more and more
like god so you enter more and more into your god
and he will enable you to understand him more and that's what
is a major part of the great joy and happiness of heaven
is that you understand him more and more
and the more you understand and the more your soul will be expanded to receive
more of that eternal rest so I want to give you a couple of
scriptures for rest Sam 62 verse 5 Sam 95 verse 11
Sam 116 verse 7 Sam 132 verse 14 so your soul will be expanded in order to
receive that eternal rest with all the happiness and joy
which the divine rest contains all what a beautiful rest this will be for you
a rest which can be found only in the divine will
now while he was saying this luisa said he came out from within my interior and
throwing his arms around my neck he'd clasped me tightly to himself
and I stretched out my arms and clasped him tightly to myself
and in the meantime my sweet Jesus was calling many people
who were clinging to his feet now he's giving her a taste
of the generations in the divine will that are coming
at the time that he is talking to her he's saying that these souls are clinging
to his feet and he will raise them right up to live in his divine will
so then he disappeared so let's come to july the ninth
1925 but you're now going to hear something
more about suffering together with Jesus now people in the world
suffer on their own which is very sad it's it's kind of useless and it can
be utterly depressing for them and all the rest of it
but someone in union with Jesus and someone living in the divine will
suffering with Jesus can have absolutely extraordinary effects on the earth
watch it watch what Jesus is going to say
so luisa begins by saying I felt I could no longer be without my sweet Jesus
for several days I had to long for his return but in vain
I would say to him from my heart my love come back to your little daughter
I don't you see that I can take no more add to what a hard martyrdom you expose
my poor existence by depriving me of yourself
and tired and exhausted I would abandon myself to his divine will there's the
solution you're in a situation you can't solve it
and the solution is abandon yourself to the divine will
so while I was in this state of abandonment to the divine will
I was reading and I felt somebody extending his arms around my neck
my mind became drowsy and I found myself clasped in the arms of Jesus
all overshadowed and hidden in him so we've been introduced
to the meaning of that the overshadowing is terribly important
because you're told at the incarnation that the holy spirit overshadowed that
is completely covered our blessed mother so here she's completely overshadowed
by Jesus I wanted to tell him of my sorrow but he gave me no time
he's been blocking her for the whole of volume 17
from telling her her troubles he's trying to get her to put them aside
and only think of him then he spoke to me and he said my daughter
don't you want to convince yourself when my justice for a just reason wants to
chastise people I'm forced to hide from you now he's been telling her that since
volume one and she doesn't want to take it in that's why he says
don't you want to convince yourself in fact you are nothing other than a
little particle that's very interesting which binds all
other particles of the other creatures now instead of
particle I would use the term sellotape or something sticky that
connects everything else and being in a familiar relationship with you
as though in feast and wanting to strike the other particles around you
my justice finds itself in a difficult situation
and feels dissuaded from striking the other ones so
during the past few days he said I had to do some justice lunch you know
the strike was saying well I was busy I'm sorry I couldn't answer the phone
he said I just had to do a few adjustments and the very the very way he says that
tells you you're dealing with the Lord of the world
so I couldn't come to you so let's come to the next paragraph
as he was saying this Louisa said I found myself outside of myself and he
showed me how on various points of the earth there had been earthquakes
so I want to give you amos three seven for that the Lord doesn't do anything
without telling the prophets first and at some places there were grave fires
with the deaths of people and in other places and other troubles
and so on and it seemed that the more grave
evils would actually follow that Louisa is seeing things
in the future some of the stuff that Jesus showed to her
actually happened in her own lifetime some of it was for the future
I was frightened she said and I prayed because that was the whole idea
and then my beloved Jesus came back and before him
I saw myself totally ugly as though withered and I said to him
my life and my all look at me how ugly I have become
Sam 22 verses 6 to 8 how I'm about to wither
and how I change without you your privation makes me lose the freshness
the beauty that you've given to me I feel I'm under a scorching sun
that's draining all of the vital humors and makes me wither and be consumed
and then Jesus made me suffer a little bit
together with him now watch this she's feeling
withered and falling apart and dying and as a solution
to that Jesus gives her a little bit of suffering
and she said that suffering turned into a celestial Jew
over my soul which restored the vital humors in me
and then taking my poor soul in his hands he added poor daughter of mine
don't fear if my privation made you wither
my return will give you back all the freshness and the beauty and the color
and everything else and your suffering together with me
will not only be like Jew now watch this carefully
which rejuvenates you but will serve as a continuous knocking
with which I can knock at the doors of your soul revelation 3 20
and you can knock at mine so that the doors may always be open
John 10 verses 7 and 9 Jesus is the gate or the door
and you can enter freely into me so notice the tiny little bit of suffering
he says it makes all the difference it's like the salt on your food
and we have to be salted he tells us that in the sermon on the mound
but he's knocking at the the door of the human race now and he wants us to open
it with the fiat proclaimed in public and so
all the little things that we have to suffer or go through between now
and the 15th of August please they're pure gold
extremely important okay you can enter freely into me and I into you he said
and my breath will serve you as a breeze to preserve you in the beautiful
freshness with which I created you and as he was saying this
he blew very strongly over me that's really wonderful
that's what he did in John 20 now I think it's verse 23 when he
breathed over the apostles after the resurrection
to bring them to life spiritually so let's come to July the 20th 1925
and Jesus puts Louisa into a state of immobility
which is actually quite frightening but we we know
what's going on because he gives her an experience that explains something he
wants to say to us about himself as I was in my usual state
going through most bitter privations of my sweet Jesus
finally he made himself seen and without saying even a word he put me in a
painful position of complete immobility I felt the life
but I had no motion I felt the breath but I couldn't breathe
my whole person I couldn't have even the slightest motion
that is extremely painful and while feeling pain I was unable to
ride because of the pain that I felt but I was forced by the presence of
Jesus and by his most holy will to remain
completely immobile then my blessed Jesus
pleased to do so he extended his arms as though to grab me and
clasp me to his bosom and he said my daughter have you seen how painful
is the state of mobility immobility it is the hardest state because motion
is life and we need to move because even while feeling bitter
pain's motion is relief because it's a sign of life
contortions are mute voices which ask for help
and stir those around to have compassion you've experienced how
painful that is but do you know why I put you in that state of immobility
this is he gives her the experience and then he explains it he said
I want to make you understand the state in which my grace finds itself
and I need reparation from you now if you go back to volume two you'll have
Jesus saying I am grace because grace is an outpouring of God's love
upon us so if he's saying that his grace is immobile
in society then you can see that people are spiritually dead
and he's asking her to make reparation oh in what a state of immobility does my
grace find itself grace is life and it is continuous motion
because it's an outflow from God to us it is the continuous act of giving
itself to creatures this is God continuously giving himself life
love peace joy forgiveness everything but creatures rejected
and render it immobile grace feels the life
and it wants to give life but it's forced by human in gratitude
to remain immobile and without motion what pain he said my grace is light
see grace is light grace is love God is light God is love
grace is God my grace is light and as light it naturally spreads
but the creatures do nothing but release darkness
that's John 3 19 to 21 and while my light wants to enter into them
the darkness which they spread paralyzes my light
and renders it as though immobile and without life
for the creatures my grace is love and contains the power of being able to
ignite everyone but the creature the human creature
loving something else renders this love as though dead for itself
and my grace feels the most harrowing pain of the state of immobility
that creatures put into it fusions for 30 grieving the Holy Spirit
Jesus has given Louis a graphic illustration
of something we're not able to feel and that is
that the human will is able to block not only the divine will taking over
but is able to block the divine entrance completely
it's able to keep God out completely and if society keeps God out completely
either we make reparation for that to open those doors again and that you
can see understand therefore why we've been talking about opening doors
or there will be terrible chastisements because
the Lord doesn't want society to land in hell
so he will have to do the operation without the anaesthetic
so he now is going to he's now going to tell us in the next
paragraph what are the blocks
he's not going to leave us in any doubt about what they are
so he said in what most painful constraints does my grace find itself
and this not only from those who openly are said to be evil
but also from those who are said to be religious
and to be pious souls there's the scandal
now we've had this scandal going on for years and years and years
coming from people who are supposed to be completely committed to God
and many times because of trifles because of something that's not to
their liking a mere whim a most vile attachment
and because they do not find the satisfaction of their own wills
even in the very holy things that's the thing I illustrated earlier
that if they get no satisfaction out of prayer they won't pray
they won't go to mass if they don't like the singing
the choir isn't their liking they prefer this kind of choir or that kind
of choir the other kind of choir and to me it's a very sad thing that
the church has responded to that so we end up thinking that mass is
something where you will be entertained instead of a place where
you put yourself completely on the altar
and offer yourself with Jesus on that sacrificial altar
to be consecrated and transformed into him
and to become bred to feel the hungry we're supposed to be transformed
and so just because they don't get their satisfaction
of their own wills even in very holy things that's why I illustrated the mass
while my grace is all emotion and life for them
they render it immobile and they cling notice the cling
to what they like they cling to their whim they cling to human attachments
and they cling to everything in which they feel the satisfaction of their own
self so the Lord has put it blatantly clear
it's either self or god it's either human will
or divine will and when it's put here like that there isn't a choice
so in the place of my grace they put their own
self as life in other words the operating principle within us
and as their own idol now this is the problem
that has turned up in a huge way in the 20th century
and has gone to its limits I hope it says limits anyway
in the 21st century it's called autolotry
idolatry is to make an idol of something else
autolotry is to make an idol of yourself
people worship their own bodies it has to be a particular size a particular shape
it has to be a particular color it has to be a particular everything
it's incredible and to me the image of this autolotry
is the selfie I will glorify me even if nobody else does
and of course then they're told to assert themselves
sell themselves and all the rest of it so he has made it perfectly clear
here that what the issue is is the self or god
the human will or the divine will and we've got it
all those attachments have got to go sometimes you don't even know you're
attached to something until somebody wants it
make sure if somebody asks you for something you really like
that you're willing to let it go in other words that you've handed the
ownership of everything you are and everything you have
to the lord it is actually his let's come to the opposite of that now
but do you know who is the comforter and indivisible companion
the enrapturer who raptures the motion and the life of my grace and even more
she accelerates its motion more and more
and does not render it immobile nor even for one instant
it's the one who lives in the divine will the exact opposite
where my will reigns my grace is always in motion
it is always in feast it's always has something to do
it's never left grieving Ephesians 4 30 never left grieving or idle
the soul in whom my will reigns is the favorite
of my grace naturally allowing god to be god
she is its little secretary in whom it deposits the secrets of its sorrows
and its joys the divine will entrusts everything to her
because my will has sufficient space to receive the deposit
which my grace contains because she's nothing other than a continuous
birth from the divine will so if any of us are still hesitating about
going public with that fear to the lord which is so essential in 2020
jesus said you will be a continuous birth from my will
in other words i'm born every single second i don't worry about being born
for a second don't know about you so it's very good
that in august the second 1925 louisa bursts out with her
i love you for everything it's really lovely so this is this is more a prayer
than anything else i was praying infusing myself
in the holy divine volition i wanted to go around everywhere
up to the empyreium that is to god's own dwelling
and in order to find that supreme i love you which is not subject to any
interruption i wanted to make it my own
so that i too might have and i love you never
interrupted to see if it's a divine i love you it's not interrupted okay
which might echo the eternal i love you and by possessing within itself
the source of the true i love you i might have and i love you for all
for each one for each motion for each act for each breath for each
heartbeat and for each i love you of my jesus himself
so in this prayer louisa is actually illustrating
what jesus has just been saying about the person living in the divine will
actually giving grace and opportunity to do all kinds of things
as i seemed to reach the bosom of the eternal one louisa said
uh making there i love you my own so that it's an eternal one
i kept repeating everywhere and upon each thing
a sing song of i love yous for my supreme lord very childlike and beautiful
now while i was doing this my thought interrupted my i love you telling me
what are you doing you could be doing something else
i see you see the rational mind moving in here
what's this i love you how special is all that
and my sweet jesus as though moving hurriedly in my interior told me what
how special is all the i love you for me my daughter the i love you is
everything the i love you is love veneration
esteem heroism its sacrifice its trust towards the one
to whom it's directed the i love you is to possess the one who encloses the i
love you the i love you is a small word but it
weighs as much as the whole eternity the i love you encloses everything
envelopes everyone it diffuses it restricts itself and it rises up high
it descends down below it impresses itself absolutely everywhere
but it never stops how can you say this my daughter how special is all this i
love you its origin is eternal in the i love you
number one the celestial father generated me
and in the i love you number two the holy spirit proceeded
number three in the i love you the eternal fear
issued the whole of creation number four and in the i love you it forgave
guilty man and redeemed him so in the i love you the soul finds
everything in god and god finds everything in the soul
therefore the value of the i love you is infinite
it's full of life and of energy it never tires it surpasses everything
and it triumphs over everything and so this i love you for me
i want to see on your lips in your heart in the flight of your thoughts in
the drops of your blood in the pains in the joys in the food you take
in everything the life of my i love you must be very
very long in you and my fiat reigning in you will place on it the seal
of the divine i love you well there's jesus answer
don't think it requires a comment so after this
louisa said a sun made itself present to my mind at an extremely high point
now the sun is at the light at one timothy six sixteen god dwells
in unapproachable light its light was inaccessible
from the center of it came out continuous little flames
each one containing and i love you and as they were coming out they placed
themselves as though in order around this inaccessible light
however these little flames remained as though bound to a thread of of light
to that inaccessible light which nourished the life of the little flames
these little flames were so many as to fill heaven and earth
i seem to see our god as the beginning and the origin
of everything and the little flames the whole of creation
i saw as a divine birth and of pure love i too was a little flame
and my sweet jesus pushed me to take flight through each
other little flame in order to place on them the double i love you
his and mine i don't know how i found myself outside of myself
to go around in the midst of those little flames
and impress my i love you on each one of them
but there were so many i would get lost however a supreme force which is the
divine will made me resume in order the order
and the round of my i love you then afterwards she said i found myself
inside a vast garden and to my surprise i found my queen mother
who drawing me near told me my daughter come with me to work in this garden
now that sounds awfully like the song of songs
chapter six verses 10 to 11 where the bride is invited
to go and work in the lord's vineyard we must plant in its celestial and
divine flowers and fruits Galatians 5 22
it's now almost empty and if there's any plant at all
it is terrestrial and human in other words we've not yet moved
into the era of the divine will therefore we have to root them out
so that this garden may be fully pleasing to my son jesus
the seeds which we must plant are all of my virtues
and my works and my pains which contain the seed of the fiat fund
will unto us too because our blessed mother had the
divine will in her soul from the first moment of her life
there was nothing i did which did not contain this seed of the will of god
i would have contented myself with doing nothing
rather than operating or suffering without the seed
all my glory the dignity of mother the height or the glory of being queen
the supremacy overall came to me from that seed of the divine will
the whole of creation all beings recognized me as dominating over them
because they saw in me reigning the supreme will
so the big difference is that the divine will
was in everything in her therefore we that our blessed mother and luisa
will unite everything i did together with everything you have done
with this seed of the supreme volition and we'll plant this little garden in
other words preparing the future full of hope for the rest of us
to go into the same garden and to put our little seeds in
so we fused the seeds beautiful which my celestial mother
had which were many and together with the few of mine
and i don't know how i found she said and we began to form little holes
and to plant the seeds but while we were doing this from behind the walls of
the garden which were extremely high we heard noises of weapons and cannons
and that they were fighting in a horrible way we were forced to run in
order to give help it noticed that this preparation
for the divine will is going on while there's world wars going on
and all the rest of us and and also while there is huge opposition
to the church the walls are extremely high now when you come to the new
Jerusalem at the end of the book of revelation you'll be told that the
walls are extremely high in other words there are certain
people who cannot come in because they're not in the right relationship so she
said we were forced to run and give them help and as we arrived we saw
peoples of various races of different colors and many nations united together
and they were battling and striking uh there was terror and fright
but while i was seeing this i found myself inside of myself with such
fright she said that also with the sorrow of having said not even a word to my
celestial mother about my heart state now notice that she's been blocked from
talking about herself and she has this this urge in her all the time i want
to tell them how difficult everything is so
may the holy will of god be always blessed and may everything be for his glory
i think that that image there of louisa working with our blessed mother
to sow the seeds for the new era of the kingdom of the divine will
is absolutely beautiful and notice they do it regardless of what's going on in
society and that's what the lord wants us to do as well
take your eyes off what the world is doing and what the world is saying and
all the rest of it and get on with sowing the seeds
of the acts in the divine will to prepare the future for them all
so we now come to the last text in volume 17
and it's august the fourth 1925 so one who lives in the divine will
is in communication with all of creation
so louisa said after going through various days of total privation of my
sweet jesus i kept repeating my sorrowful refrain
everything is over for me i'll never see him again
i will never hear his voice again so much delight at me
i've been abandoned by the one who formed all of my contentment and was
everything to me what a prolonged martyrdom
life without jesus without jesus but while my heart was drowned with pains
my sweet jesus came out from within my interior because he's there all the
time and as he took me in his arms i threw my
arms around his neck abandoning my head upon his breast
because i could take no more and jesus squeezing me tightly to himself
leaned his knees on my breast now you're not meant to take this physically
right pressing on it very strongly and said to me
my daughter you must die continuously what he's saying to her
in all of the privation and the suffering and everything else
we have got to die continuously to ourselves
we want a life of just peace and joy and happiness
but that is for heaven you do have peace and joy and happiness in the depths of
your being living in the divine will but you're still living on the earth
there's still awful things happening on the earth there's still more work that
the lord wants to do in us and so we have to die
daily but st. paul told us that just go to the letters of st. paul
he said very clearly you've got to die daily in other words the human will
has this awful propensity to move back and push back and push back and we've
got to keep pushing it back so the surrendering to the lord
is every moment of every day for the rest of our days
you must die continuously he said and as he was saying this
he shared various pains with me and then assuming a more affable look he
said my daughter what do you fear if in you
there is the power of my will now we're at the end of volume 17
we're about to go to the one that the volume that's
halfway through and i find it fascinating
that with all the experience that louisa has
she still hasn't grasped i i mean in a practical sense
she hasn't grasped the sheer power of the divine will working in her
and i think that this is being said to illustrate our problem
that we can't believe it's at the we okay we accept it and it's written
there and we say yes to it and we want it and all the rest of it but
in our everyday actions we find it difficult to
actually take on board the fact that there's a divine will
operating in us and it's true he said that this will of mine
is in you that in one instant i transformed you
into my pains and you would love offered yourself to receive them
and as you were suffering you stretched out your arms to embrace my will
and while you were embracing the divine will everything that lives in my will
that's the angels the saints by celestial mother and the very divinity
felt the tightness of your embrace really underlined that
if you're in the divine will all of the heavenly dwellers experience
what you're doing they felt the tightness of your embrace
and they all ran towards you to embrace you in return
and in course they said how pleasing and dear
is the embrace of our little exiled one who lives on earth to do the will of
god alone just as we do it in heaven so he's
saying to her that while you're experiencing the
suffering side of the divine will those who are experiencing the joy
side of the divine will are looking in fascination at an ordinary person who
was born with original sin like everybody else
is now living as they're living and they're looking in total amazement at
this she's our joy she is the new and only
feast that comes to us from the earth and Jesus said to her if you only knew
what it means to live in my will there's no division between the soul and
heaven you see we know the words but it's so
hard to take it on board whatever my will is she is also
her act her pains her words are in act and operating in any place where the
divine will is present and since the divine will is
everywhere the soul places herself in the order of creation
and through the power of the supreme volition
she's in communication with all creation things
and just as created things are in order and harmony among themselves
each one is the support of the other and not one of them can move
from their place and may this never be if just one thing created by me
should move the creation would be all upset there's an extraordinary
balance in the planets in the stars the astrophysicists are still
absolutely fascinated that they just seem to be hanging
there in space i mean what's whole it just
just think of the weight of planet earth and it's one of the smaller
planets in the solar system some planets are twice the size of it
what's holding it up they're beginning to grasp that there's a
an extraordinary balance in the whole of creation and Jesus is saying that
when the divine will comes to reign in us then we could actually upset that
balance so if any of them could move from their
place he said the whole of creation would be upset
there is a secret among them the astrophysicists want
the next sentence terribly there is a secret among them
a mysterious force such that while they live suspended in the air without any
support by the force of communication which
they have among themselves each one sustains the other
and that's how he wants us as a community of beings on the the earth
to operate as well that we all look after each other
and therefore everybody thrives but when everybody's in their own little place
only looking after themselves nobody thrives
i think that's fantastic by a mysterious force that while they live
suspended in the air without any support by the force of communication
which they have among themselves each one sustains the other
in the same way one who does my will is in communication
with everybody else and is sustained by all the works
of her creator therefore all recognizer all love her
and all offer her the electricity or the power
and the secret of living together with them suspended between heaven and earth
all sustained by the wonderful supreme force of the divine will
i love that paragraph i think it's fantastic because
i i love anything to do with the stars and the creation
and i love listening to what the the scientists are saying
so i'm going to stop there because we have finished volume seven